did you guys know
that originally
will smith was approached by quentin
tarantino to play
django and django unchained and he
turned down the role he recently talked
about well not recently but like a
couple years ago we talked about it in
an interview of one of those actors
roundtables it had to be a love story
not a vengeance story oh i don't believe
in violence as the reaction okay ladies
and gentlemen okay so
i just got back from an oscar's party
now generally i've kind of given up on
the oscars i think they can be quite
boring the awards don't really mean much
to me i haven't even seen most of the
films that actually came out that were
nominated to be honest so in my mind i
was like look this
i'm just going to hang out with some
friends i was surprisingly getting most
of my picks right because the officers
can be really predictable when it comes
to nominations and stuff and then the
greatest thing in oscar's history ever
happened this is a night to remember
ladies and gentlemen history
memes for weeks the most talked about
thing on the internet like i thought the
most talked about thing coming out of
the oscars would be that random category
they were presenting for like fan
favorite cheer moment and then zack
sanders justice league one and then fan
favorite movie and zack snyder's army of
the dead one i was like this is where
all the talk on twitter is gonna be
about it's gonna be all about this i was
wrong like
10 minutes later i was way wrong in case
you guys don't know i'm so shocked if
you don't but in case you guys don't
know chris rock presented an award for
best documentary i believe that was the
category and then he was making some
jokes it's chris rocker expecting to
make some jokes he made some jokes about
penelope cruz and hobby of our damn
couples jokes as chris rock likes to
make couples jokes will smith jada
pinkett smith sitting front row at the
oscars he made a joke about jada pinkett
smith saying i can't wait to see you in
g.i jane too
apparently
big willy got provoked smack the crap
out of chris rock and change oscars
forever set a precedent apparently you
can go up to people smack the presenter
and nothing's gonna happen to you
depending on your star level and the
clout you have for that night and the
fact that you're gonna win an award that
evening it it was wild i'm gonna ask you
guys right up front what did you think
about what happened what was your
reaction to it how do you feel overall
who was right who was wrong i want to
hear your thoughts in the comments below
i'm going to talk you guys through my
reaction of experiencing this and then
i'm also going to give some of my
thoughts and feelings on it as well the
officers are going they're going fine
it's actually a pretty enjoyable oscars
for the most part amy schumer's doing a
great job when chris rock is out there
presenting the award he's doing his
speech and then here's what happened he
makes the g.i jane joke and i can't i
could show you some footage but i can't
play it because i know this video will
get blocked because i know abc is he
makes the joke and then at first
will smith he's laughing
he's laughing so i was like everything
just seems fine he's laughing about it
jada pinkett smith
evidently
not happy at all it is so apparent she
is not happy cuts back to chris rock
he's doing his thing and the crowd at
first is going oh and chris rock said
something to the effect of like it was a
light one or whatever like it wasn't
that bad of a joke and in my mind like
it's not that bad of a joke she has a
she has a shaved head and then he said
gij like that's an old ass movie like
this is a stupid joke will smith starts
walking up to him you see chris rock
laughing his ass off at will smith
approaching him we only see the back of
will smith said so we don't know what
will smith's face looks like in that
moment so will smith walks up to him
chris roger leaned in almost as if he's
like come on in and hit me like his face
is leaned in with laughter i thought
will smith was just gonna get on the mic
or some [ __ ] i thought that's all he was
gonna do was just freaking like start
making a joke or make a joke about chris
rock or whatever all of a sudden bam oh
wow like the perfect form
perfect form the all lead days of will
smith come out it was a great hit all
things considered you know it's great
assault yes but a great hit over
probably smith then he goes back down
now if you live in australia you got the
uncensored version and apparently you
can find the audio the actually
uncensored version on sites like youtube
and twitter but in the states
in our mind when he smacked him it
looked like a bit because you know like
chris rock didn't fall down or whatever
all of us thought it was like some weird
joke and chris rock says will smith just
smacked the um out of me that's how it
sounded to us and then all the audio
went out and you're cutting back to will
smith who's looking pissed off and you
can see chris rock feeling pretty
awkward about the whole ordeal and then
it starts to register with us like i
think this is actually very real i think
will smith just got really mad about a
joke that he just seemed
like fine with a second ago and then got
up there got very reactive and smacked
the [ __ ] out of chris rock here's what i
think really happened at least this is
how what what i in the moment what i
thought happened chris rock made a funny
will smith laughed at the funny looked
to his wife
wife didn't find it funny well smith
realized i'm gonna be in the doghouse
unless i do something about this i gotta
stand up for her because i know what
it's like when you're in a relationship
and you think something's funny that
your significant other doesn't that's at
the expense of her then you're like oh
[ __ ] i shouldn't have laughed at that i
need to correct this now so he did the
one thing he could do walk up on stage
and smack the [ __ ] out of chris
that's how it just registered to me in
the moment it was crazy and what made it
crazier we went crazier for all of us is
the fact that we all knew will smith was
going to win that night there was no
question about it so it just made it go
out of all nights like it's already a
bad night to do like you never just want
to do that but out of any night to do
this on the night you're finally going
to win your oscar this happens like what
is your speech going to be what is your
speech going to be so on the uncensored
version when i watched it on the car
ride home after chris rock says will's
just smacked the [ __ ] out of me will
smith says keep my wife's name out of
your [ __ ] mouth chris rock was like
dude it was a g.i jane joke at the time
i was like considering the same thing
dude she's a gi jin joe chill out you're
a couple who's in the public spotlight
like all the time
your relationship seems to be like on
blast you even did a sit-down interview
where you really exposed a lot of things
about your relationship right away when
you're that level of celebrity and
you're allowing yourself to be that
exposed usually that means like
entertainers comedians people are going
to make jokes at you and just kind of
kind of be ready for it if you're going
to be willing to expose that society
that's just how i was registering at the
time there was other information that
was yet to learn
but at the time that's how i was
thinking about it will smith did further
in real anger like rage keep my wife's
name out of your
mouth if i say too hard youtube gets a
little sentimental about the whole thing
and then chris rock made a little crack
of this was the best night in television
history or so you made a joke about
something like that it is it made the
oscars truly exciting more exciting than
it's ever been that was crazy so come to
find out uh i did not know this
apparently jada has actually been very
public about this but i don't follow the
lives of them the question is did chris
rock know about this says she has a
disease called alopecia it's medical
term for baldness so she suffers from
baldness so it's not her fault that
she's bald it's a condition that she has
and that's really unfortunate and that
just changes the whole context of the
joke right there there's several ways
comedian because comedians seem to
always be defending themselves against
like the free will to make a joke about
anything and anybody i get that a lot of
comedians feel that way so i i don't
know if chris rock didn't knew that or
not or he did know that and he was like
i can still make a joke anyway because i
don't think the joke's that bad that is
a very sensitive thing to say in front
of like millions of people it's not
really about what chris rock believes if
that's offensive or not it's more about
how will the person on the receiving end
of that comment how will they feel about
that and if jada's the kind of
individual to be hurt and offended by
that then you shouldn't make that joke
especially if you already know that she
has this disease that she probably would
not want to be made fun about and one of
the biggest nights in their life because
they're husband and wife just having the
spotlight put on you like that
see i i can get that the question is
should will smith walked up there and
smack the [ __ ] out of chris rock
probably not that was probably not the
way to handle it i know that there's
most likely a lot of women across the
world a lot of people maybe not just
women but a lot of men too who are like
you know if i was made fun of in public
i would expect my man to go up there and
just beat the [ __ ] out of that guy
and to me i'm like well it really
depends on the situation at hand you
know if this is the oscars yeah i might
mike i might give a look like i'm pretty
upset by that joke but i'm not going to
go up there and smack the guy i mean hey
i could get i could get arrested or
fined for assault or something like that
like this this is not a good look and
then it just started making me kill the
fact that will smith just kind of got
away with it started making me go too
does will smith just like do this does
he when he gets mad at people does he
just smack them like has he's just
smacked people on set before like what's
his attitude like if there's a joke
that's made that you just you just can't
roll with because it comes in the name
of protection and love because he gave
this speech and in between before his
oscar win his publicist was talking to
him a lot there's like photos of like
denzel talking to him and tyler perry i
believe like there's there's people
congregating with him to talk him
through it and seem like there was a lot
of people in support of him in that
moment you know like he got sensitive he
was provoked something happened and
you're in a room full of a bunch of
artists who are all very sensitive
individuals who also practice the art of
empathy they're not going to be like
social media about it you know they're
all there's going to be a lot more
understanding they probably know will
they definitely know will smith better
than either one of us makes sense how
he's going to have a lot of support
surrounding him in a moment like that
and it seems like a lot we're on a side
at least that's the way it appeared that
was the impression given off so will
smith gives his speech you know we're
all like
what's he going to say you know what's
will smith going to talk about is he
going to is he metro chris rock he's
going to talk [ __ ] about it he
immediately starts to talk about people
he had to protect people involved with
the movie characters real life people
talking about how love makes you do
crazy things and the way
he gave his speech made our friend
brandon hannah in the roommate the best
comment ever
that man has a damn good publicist he
really does because holy balls it was a
great speech there's still like when you
revisit the situation that happened i'm
like does the speech eliminate you know
all with everything that happened no it
definitely doesn't in the moment of time
you're like damn that's a powerful
speech it seems really sincere seems
very emotional and i at least get where
he's coming from at this moment in time
and it seemed like at least the way the
narrative suddenly changed on that it
was all coming from a place of not
necessarily ego but a place of
protecting a loved one and especially
when you find out that jada has alopecia
you're like okay like he was really
going out there protecting her
i still think there are other ways it
could have been handled but he had a
human moment he's human i've met plenty
of people who've started a fight they
shouldn't have had they
felt like they regretted that they maybe
shouldn't have done it wilson apologized
to the academy he apologized to his to
his fellow nominees didn't apologize
chris rocco but he apologized to other
people and i'm wondering too like is
there more history with him in chris
rock because i know that like a few
years ago when it came to the whole
boycott in the oscar situation chris
rock when he was hosting the oscars made
a joke directed at them wasn't about
this but he made a joke at them so maybe
there's more of a history there that we
don't really know i think he could have
handled it differently i think he could
have like you know like at least
displayed that he wasn't happy with it
hell if you even if he just yelled
instead of you know actually going there
and hitting him because that is an act
of violence that's bad it's like that
thing of like dude i totally get it you
were standing up for the woman you love
i totally understand you guys have had a
lot of heat on you and there's always
seems like the media is trying to take
you guys down so you're protecting her
in this moment that's supposed to just
be a beautiful night like i get it you
probably shouldn't have smacked her
chris rock you probably shouldn't have
made that joke but you're like whoa guys
both of you probably shouldn't have done
this i totally understand that
regardless how do i feel about this
it weirdly made for the most
entertaining night in oscar history
like this was uh this was a night to
remember it was it was wild and that
fact that that [ __ ] got put on display
good job to will smith's publicist good
job to a support team congratulations
will smith on winning that oscar and man
i would never [ __ ] with that guy it's
just crazy because he always comes
across as like the nicest dude ever he
oh and even in that moment you're just
like he seemed like he was just
protecting her
but
holy crap like he'll just go up to you
and hit you if you do something wrong
that was uh
that was that was pretty crazy i just
thought i'm gonna be like thinking about
this all the time and talking about it
for a very long time so i just want to
hop on camera but you guys talking about
it really quick thanks for being here
chit chat soon
[Music]
you